you know that metal plate in my head  how can i forget i had to have her  replace because every time catherine  revved up the microwave i'd piss my  pants and forget who i was for a half  hour or so so over at the va they had to  replace it with a plastic one and it  ain't as strong so  i don't know if all to go say when there  are no hell with nothing between the  ground and my brain but a piece of  government plastic  i'm here at slumberton hill or as the  kids who showed up here today like to  call it  suicide hill and what better way to say  yeah  a winter than with a good old-fashioned  toboggan ride  hey dad now i'm gonna ask my friends  here to give me just a little push  i sent a little one  and i'm going to die  oh  oh  you